in the midst of the YouTube advertiser
boycott the hey tree 'it's continued to
write in let's start to get into hey
tree at mail for the week the right of
the people to keep and bear hates shall
not be in friend Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right
this week's hatred mail doesn't really
need an introduction so we'll just jump
right in
treasonous scumbag you disgusting vile
piece of climate change is a fraud how
many times does this fact have to be
brought up chemtrails are killing all
life on this planet not humans
chemtrails
journalist uncovers IPCC fraud Putin is
against chemtrails you are a treasonous
scumbag without having to really
deconstruct the specifics of this hatred
mail this is why what's going on with
the YouTube ad boycott is so crucial
people like this hatred that are just
waiting for us to go off the air for
reasons they can barely even articulate
nor understand
and we're working not to let it happen
because there's no making sense out of
that but clearly this hatred watches a
lot of Alex Jones I think yeah that's
fair to assume I mean I would imagine
that his show is being impacted by this
- yeah I went on the Alex Jones channel
and there were very few ads playing
there as well so listen you can push
back against this degree of hate reott
ISM go to patreon.com/scishow throw in a
few bucks or you can use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 when you sign up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership